vera bonjour c'est donc une campagne de
vaccination à grande échelle qui
commence ce matin en russie
bonjour olivier oui effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est le début de la
vaccination de masse à mouscou plus de
5000 personnes ont recouru aux services
d'inscription en ligne prioritaire dès
son ouverture afin de demander de se
faire vacciner
la campagne de vaccination de masse a
commencé donc aujourd'hui à moscou et
dans sa banlieue
la vaccination dans la capitale russe
concerne d'abord les personnes à risque
c'est à dire les gens qui travaillent
dans les domaines de la santé
l'éducation et dans la sphère sociale
je vous propose d'écouter le médecin
chef d'une des polycliniques moscovite
qui a déjà accueilli les premières
volontaire aujourd'hui la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc villeneuve a
été lancée dans la ville il ya 70
centres de vaccination y compris dans
notre branche numéro vite où nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui il ya suffisamment
de patients enregistrés pour que cela
soit considéré comme un bon début de
campagne de vaccination plus de 20
personnes ont déjà été vaccinées
en fait tous les patients ont une
attitude très positive et attendre que
le vaccin soit efficace
nous avons également pu échanger avec
les premiers volontaires qui sont venues
se faire vacciner écoutez je travaille
en contact direct avec les enfants dans
le domaine de l'éducation
complémentaires
j'enseigne la chorégraphie c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas de distance entre -1 et
les enfants comme c'est le cas avec
d'autres enseignants
il ya une communication tactile avec les
enfants pour corriger tel ou tel
mouvement
je pense que la vaccination est un
excellent moyen de me protéger et
surtout de protéger mes proches mes
parents qui ont plus de 65 ans contre ce
virus
j'ai donc été heureux de profiter de
cette opportunité dès qu'elle s'est
présentée
pour le moment c'est le tout premier
vaccin russe qui a été approuvée
spoutnik et qui est utilisé dans la
vaccination de masse selon le ministre
de la santé micro mou rage que plus de
cent mille personnes ont déjà reçu ce
remède dont l'efficacité est estimé à la
hauteur de 95%
deux autres vaccins russes encore en
deuxième phase des essais cliniques
produit par les centres de recherche
vecteur de novossibirsk et tu m'as
coffre de moscou vont s'ajouter à la
liste des débuts 2021 merci beaucoup
vera pour toutes ces précisions
verhaeghe hoffman en direct de moscou